hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
from Monday April 1st April 1st wait a
minute isn't this when everybody fools
everybody look at all these [ __ ]
wires I'll jammed around together out of
[ __ ] does this happen every week well
bill cuz you just you just throw it
around you throw our you throw around
your equipment it gets all [ __ ]
locked together I'm happy April Fool's
Day everybody we're into month for an
old Billy no booze is [ __ ] cruising
along for months into this [ __ ] thing
November 24th so I don't know that's 120
some 27 days 28 days as of today which
is the longest I think I've gone since
that time I took a year off so my record
is 367 days since I first started
boozing around 17 years old so the first
17 years of my life I cruised other than
you know I snuck a beer here or there
you know when I was in my teens because
I didn't want my first beer that I ever
had to be in front of other [ __ ]
people I remember my dad had Stroh's
that's what he used to drink he had
strokes I don't know if they still make
that [ __ ] he had it in the refrigerator
and I would [ __ ] you know sneak one
not realising you had no idea how [ __ ]
him up am I gonna get and I would I
would only drink like a third of it and
then I would I would pour the thing out
the rest of it down the [ __ ] sink that
was my big foray into everything
everything I've ever done I always stuck
my toe into it like ooh what bad things
gonna happen so which is probably better
for you you know long-term but I will
tell you one thing you know going to bed
sober really makes you kind of force
face your uh your [ __ ] demons man I
was really thinking like uh you know I
drink to take the edge off little stress
you know it's nice it's nice to just
have one and just [ __ ] relax which it
is hos kiddin ho it's [ __ ] delicious
oh my god I got a ow Jesus Christ III
you know the amount of times I've gone
it's starting to fade but you know these
first few [ __ ] months man it's been a
couple of bars that I've seen and I just
think especially during the day I just
think like what would happen if I just
went in there right [ __ ] now marched
right in there got a beer and a shot and
just did that for the next four hours
came home then I come home to my wife
and kid at 4:30 in the afternoon
hammered and then what you know knew
you'd be looking at me like what are we
in [ __ ] Angela's Ashes kind of an
[ __ ] in 2019 with the wife and kid at
home goes out and gets [ __ ] hammered
at a bar but I'll tell you as much as I
know not to do that the thought is
definitely there but yeah so as I've
mentioned a thousand [ __ ] times and I
know you guys are getting sick of this
but I just say to you say it to you so
I'll do it
I'm taking this year off I'm not talking
to you guys right now I'm talking to me
so which I think I'll be able to do no
problem the only [ __ ] tough day that
I see between me and let's see I would
break my record I went a year in two
days November 24th 25th 26 November 22nd
7th is when I would break my record
write my own personal bests of willpower
is I'm going to the I'm gonna be going
to the Clemson Florida State football
game in October and I'm gonna be you
know we already like we have the lodging
we're gonna be out there for a couple of
days I'm actually trying to get a gig at
Clemson everybody which is probably
career suicide now with everybody with
their hashtags flipping the [ __ ] out and
all of that [ __ ] I would love to do a
gig at like sort of a pre football rally
for the Florida State game and I'm so
[ __ ] excited for that game but I'm
gonna be there with you know my best
friend's in the
world and I know I'm gonna smoke half a
box of cigars
I just got it I just can't do the
[ __ ] the oh my god is that gonna be
hard sitting on a [ __ ] lake drinking
[ __ ] Club sodas and lime with lime oh
my god
I mean you know certain times in this
country you get [ __ ] deported for
that but whatever I'm gonna do it I'll
do it the one thing I do like about not
boozing those it's really easy to keep
the [ __ ] the old pasty belly and I
had a decent [ __ ] level although I've
noticed I've started to eat a little bad
lately just because just coming home you
want to catch some sort of a something
I'm just so used to something at the end
of the [ __ ] a day that I've literally I
started drinking root beer like I'm
[ __ ] like I still have a paper route
like I'm still nine years old so I got
to watch that you know cuz that's like
hitting the crack pipe of [ __ ] sugar
you know it's it's a [ __ ] man
like people who are like straightedge
like I would love to sit down with
somebody who's just totally straight
edge and just talked to them about like
can you imagine you didn't drink you
didn't smoke and then on top of that you
actually ate like what would they call
that diet the probiotic died whatever
the [ __ ] it was remember those people
actually read up on nutrition they
barely work out and they got [ __ ] abs
and [ __ ] you know those people who truly
they they treat they treat their body
like a [ __ ] classic car you know what
I mean like you know the ones that it's
just like dude you even drive that
[ __ ] thing like every [ __ ] nut and
bolt has been chromed it's kind of I've
just been thinking about that going like
wow that's what if I treated my body
like that cuz I know I haven't I've
treated my you know I've treated my body
in the last 15 years like a station
wagon you know the family station wagon
the fake wood paneling on the side
that's kind of how I've done it so I
mean that's not like I've been you know
you know back in the day when I went to
high school in the 80s and I remember my
buddies of mine where they'd go out and
go buy like the used [ __ ] Trans Am
that went from the late 70s with the
[ __ ] screaming flaming chicken on the
hood 6.6 liter you don't say it on the
side and they the thing was always just
like car look cool it sounded cool but
it it was driven the way it was meant to
be driven for [ __ ] eight years nine
years and now you got it
and those things wouldn't yeah would
always end up [ __ ] [ __ ] in the bed my
buddies would buy him and the [ __ ]
thing would die like three months later
it would need some major goddamn work so
anyway I've been just sort of uh trying
to think like that like try to go more
in that direction like alright what if I
quit cigars or at least rein it in what
if I read a little more on nutrition you
know what if I kept reading you know and
I just assisted me what if I kept
reading and every other word out of my
mouth is you know I'm too [ __ ] stupid
right I've gotten back into like
learning French and I'm doing really
well with it now I actually got a friend
of mine that speaks French and this
person will text me only in French and I
can actually translate a lot of it now
kind of psyched and I'm just gonna keep
doing that I told you I went to that
that that private school we were trying
to find cuz a [ __ ] all the schools
out here public schools suck so now we
got to try to find a private school to
go to and we went to this one that I
really loved still loved it but the lady
there you know they teach the kids how
to speak French right some real [ __ ]
aristocrat he [ __ ] private school
[ __ ] I said hey can the parents learn it
with them and they're just like she's
like no it's too late for you and I want
to thank him for saying that because it
really motivated me I'm like you know
alright well I'll show you [ __ ] show
you all come on
know where it's going on their torts
except we'll say it all in [ __ ]
French speaking of which I took my the
love of my life my beautiful daughter to
her first movie this week I was so
excited
you know she's all about going to the
park and all of that I bought a pitch
back when of the pitch back she used to
have as a kid you know you could adjust
him a treat if we couldn't even
adjustment three different angles the
one I had was like sort of concave shape
so if he threw it at the top it would
give you a ground or you threw at the
bottom you get a pop up if you threw it
straight in it'd be like you had a
friend that you were playing catch with
so I bought a killer one of those and I
was trying to show her how to use it and
she didn't get it so she would just run
up with the ball and she hit it off the
net and then turn around and then throw
it at me and I kind of kind of getting
her to figure out how to do that stuff
and you know I know it's still it's the
toys beyond her because it's gonna come
back and hit and hit her that's what I'm
worried about but uh I gotta run the
right path I already get my my one of my
relatives got us these little hockey
nets and she actually goes watch hockey
and then like while we're watching
hockey he like she's running around this
with the stick in the ball you know and
I'm [ __ ] with my old knees is on the
floor trying to play goal and [ __ ] so
it's it's it's all coming together it's
all coming together I just needed to get
her a little bit taller and then I'm
gonna start teaching her how to drive my
[ __ ] truck but anyway so I I boobs
driving around La and I saw these
billboards that said Dumbo March 29th
and I'm like oh my god I'm gonna take my
kid to a movie she's big enough now
we're gonna go there we'll get some
popcorn and Candide some [ __ ] drinks
and the whole thing's gonna be great so
we went over there you know my wife was
gonna come with me and then at the last
second she got something she had to go
do and she goes you just go you go this
would be good you know bonding time
daughter with the dead so we go there
and I you know and first of all I
couldn't find the [ __ ] movie like
which theater we were supposed to go in
they were all numbered you know when you
can't find you gate at the airport and I
[ __ ] that whole thing up somehow I'm
like where the [ __ ] is this you know and
I went to
therapy about my anger so I'm really
trying to keep it cool and I'm just like
who came up with the numbering system
here that I can't find you know theater
number nine or whatever right so it
turns out because it was like the IMAX
Dolby surround sound [ __ ] and I was
just like wow they're going all out so
you know Solaris um said no carrying all
her stuff carrying the popcorn I'm
leaving this trail of popcorn and stuff
but I'm loving every second and we get
in there and we have like these
individual seats that like recline
so I set her in the seat next to me this
is old dude sitting next to me a couple
other people in our row we went to like
the 10:30 in the morning showing right
and I sit her down and I put the big box
up bag of popcorn right you know she's
sitting there you know a little cute
little legs right put her right between
the legs right she's just sitting there
and she's just eaten and she's just
looking over at me like I don't know
what this is but I'm in I love this
right
I'm keeping away from the candy though
you know the sugar or whatever right so
just the salt right I mean one way I do
I have this weird thing where I'm
feeding her healthy food but like also I
think a kid should have McDonald's like
I'm not gonna take it to that [ __ ]
level you know gluten free [ __ ] pizza
I mean at some point you know I don't
know it's probably a bad thing but
whatever everybody raises their kid the
way they want to like I think you gotta
have a balance of like a little more
progressive [ __ ] with also you know they
fall down you say rub some dirt on it
you know what I mean
you don't want an animal but you don't
want a [ __ ] either you gotta have that
[ __ ] that you gotta have you gotta
raise somebody that's gonna be able to
go out in the world and be able to stick
up for themselves and I think that
starts the McDonnells know anyway so
we're sitting there and the coming
attractions are happening you know and
everything's fine or whatever and she's
just eating the popcorn like she's just
like like fish to water like oh I get
this I watched this and I eat this
popcorn I sit in this great chair this
is she's not even looking at me right
and then the movie starts and it didn't
even dawn I thought it was a cartoon I
thought was an anime animated thing
right
I didn't [ __ ] realize that it was
live-action and
Tim Burton made this was not a kids
movie and it was like PG or whatever
which is you know P G's a joke but when
you got like a two-year-old you know
it's [ __ ] guys like yelling at the
elephants and being all mean you know
Hollywood's whole you know zoos are bad
circuses are bad kind of theme you know
and we got about [ __ ] three minutes
into it and she looked over at me and
she put her arms up which means you know
pick me up and I was like oh [ __ ] and it
was loud so I picked her up know she had
talked a little bit and a guy next to me
kind of looked over me like what the
[ __ ] and I'm thinking like really dude
worried Dumbo I got a little kid two
kids talking and then all of a sudden
put together oh he's looking at me like
what the [ __ ] did you bring a kid to a
Tim Burton movie for so now she's in my
arms with their head buried into my neck
which she does when she's shy when
there's too many people around or she's
uncomfortable and so now I'm sitting
there trying to be like oh hey honey
look at the elephants the elephants and
she's just sort of looking back at this
screen and then you know going back and
then after like I swear to god we made
maybe 15 minutes and I just whispered in
her ear and I just go you want to go
home to mommy and she just goes yeah all
right we're out of here
so I only saw the first 15-20 minutes of
it all I could tell you is Danny DeVito
as always crushing it I was loving him
Colin Farrell was in it I mean I was in
I was in joints Tim Burton was having a
good time you know what's funny one
before I went over there you know
somebody was trying to say you know that
thing didn't do too well on [ __ ]
Rotten Tomatoes and I'm like what the
what kind of [ __ ] where they got
five-year-olds going on Rotten Tomatoes
being like a kind of a ripoff of
Pinocchio and once I got there and I
look you know I don't know I think when
I got home was when somebody told me was
a Tim Burton movie but as I was walking
out I and I just was the whole thing
felt bad like there was a [ __ ] there
was a fight this guy was punching this
guy in the face I was like this is
[ __ ] like which is just [ __ ] I've
always watched but now I got a kid then
like what the fight this kind of uh it's
kind of a going go
pretty hard here for a kids movie I'm
such an idiot it wasn't until I left
that I looked around and I realized that
I would see all like everybody there was
like my age almost well not my age I'm
[ __ ] but the guy next to me was like
he had like ten years on me but it was
all adults so big swing and a Miss for
me and we still had a good time she
loved the popcorn you know she still
says hey she's walking around go movie
movie popcorn popcorn er yup yep
I go loud right she goes loud loud so
anyways I did at least get to experience
that which is which is pretty amazing
considering you know this is my first
kid I've ever had so I've never gotten
to you know I've never had a kid at this
age before so I never got to go take him
to do something like that which opened
up this whole world of like oh my god I
may be she gets into sports I get to go
to her games I get to take it at games
drive her friends to the games and you
know and go to movies and find out what
the hell she's into and you know hang
out before they become a teenager which
point they need their space which I get
you know it kind of gave me like like oh
this is a whole new chapter of this and
part of this ride that's gonna be really
cool because she's already stopped doing
some stuff that I loved you know but
then they you know they learn how to
talk better you know what I mean
supposed to me but uh yeah she used to
say no when you big a sweetie do you
want you you want some more cereal and
she'd put her hand out and kind of look
put her eyebrows down look at the flow
and be like no no no me and me used to
laugh and just sort of joke like loli
only need to say it once and every time
was always no I felt like I was like
trying to hang a picture on the wall and
she was like some super rich person
across the room like
no totally wrong so she doesn't do that
anymore but she does uh other stuff you
know I've gotten to do like more like
interactive you know and they're just
like a baby he just [ __ ] carrying him
around like this it's like you have the
Hope Diamond you're like terrified now
she runs around she falls down she's
fine I've gone swimming and [ __ ] with
her and all of that stuff so it's it's
really cool watching her become like a
little person so anyways anyway you guys
are telling me f1 the second race of the
year in Bahrain I watched that today and
you know I'm rooting for Ferrari just
because you know whenever I take on a
new sport
I can't root for the Patriots team or
the the the Golden State Warriors
whoever the dominant team is you can't
just like pile on and be like oh I like
the best team so Ferrari obviously
they're no slouches but they've just
been they've been in a rut since I've
been watching I think this is my third
or fourth season watching and it's let's
see well let's see Luis won it then Nico
Rosberg wanted and then Louis won it's
this is my fourth season watching I
believe or Lewis won the last two years
and Nico was Nico won the first year I
watched but I think I'm in my fourth
season of watching this stuff and I have
to be I got to tell you this right now I
swear to God what rooting for the
Ferrari team is feeling like it's it's
like rooting for the Kansas City Chiefs
or the the Toronto Maple Leafs the
[ __ ] who else San Jose Sharks the San
Diego Chargers those [ __ ] teams that
they're there right there they're right
there and then [ __ ] you gee I'm watching
this [ __ ] race and you know Lewis
Hamilton did not have a good race the
first time and you know that guy I
really like him I like what he does but
he you know he acts like a [ __ ] baby
though when he's not winning he's always
at what's what's botas doing how come
he's not helping me out it's like well
when you're leading the race you're not
thinking about helping him out you know
I never been able to like think like
is is that like how you have to be to be
as good as him you got to be that
selfish it's just really off-putting as
a fan to be watching that so I'm
watching the race the Ferraris have won
the poll and second place and then the
Mercedes are in third and fourth all
right I think this Charles Leclerc is
that I you say his name he was on pole
Vettel had a better start
and I think Leclerc or somebody was
having a problem with their grip around
the first three turn turns didn't warm
up their tires enough and botas was
breathing down in the breathing down his
[ __ ] neck you know and but then the
one would say straightened out after a
couple of [ __ ] laps the Ferraris were
like in control it was a really
interesting race and then Lewis went in
early and he got some soft tires and all
of a sudden he started [ __ ] catching
up which made Vettel have to [ __ ] pit
but like the Ferraris were just stronger
they were just better cars and just were
better today and then they did think
this thing [ __ ] the whole [ __ ] thing
up you know I was also punching up a
[ __ ] episode of efforts for family as
I'm always [ __ ] multitasking I don't
know what happened to Bella that was
front wing but he [ __ ] spins out but
Charles Leclerc it has like a [ __ ]
hear like a 25 second lead on Lewis
Hamilton and he's there's like 12 laps
to go the [ __ ] race is over and I'm
like this is great okay Hamilton's gonna
go Oh for two as far as winning races
and you know he's coming you know he's
gonna win his races maybe it'll be nice
and close for the rest of the [ __ ]
year and now 12 laps to go all of a
sudden Charlie oh I'm wrong my car -
[ __ ] the [ __ ] turbo shits the bed and
then he just got a watch [ __ ]
Hamilton run him down and then [ __ ]
botas passes him and now the Mercedes
are in first and second they have
[ __ ] Ferrari team they just [ __ ]
screwed the pooch and then at least you
know Renault wasn't was nice enough to
have both their cars [ __ ] the bed so
then they they finished under a caution
flag so
Leclerc was I think did he I think he
might have stayed on the podium and
fitnah and Vettel was kind of in fifth
place what do we got here let me see
what let me see the the positions here I
looked at up here f1 standings I have
and that's not what I want
it was Lewis Hamilton botas Leclerc and
then Oh max Verstappen and then Vettel
so he came in fifth place and then here
are the standings for the Year botas has
44 points points for Mercedes and then
Hamilton has 43 max Verstappen is at 27
and then the Ferrari team there are 26
and 22 like that now right now so now
you know what it is now like all I'm
gonna do is route for botas cuz I did
like the racing between the two
teammates botas and Hamilton like [ __ ]
you dude like botas has done being the
[ __ ] you know the bridesmaid of the
goddamned [ __ ] of that team and that
could be really fun
because that first year with Nico
Rosberg and hope him saying his name
right and Lewis Hamilton that was like
watching Days of Thunder the way they
didn't get along so let me get a drink
of water here hang on
but anyways when you know was [ __ ]
hilarious when when a Hamilton passed
Leclerc I literally gave the finger to
the TV both fingers and I'm just like
why am i mad at Louise Hamel to what cuz
he's good you know he reminds me of he's
like that remember that smart kid at
school had the great penmanship and
always [ __ ] you know did everything
that you knew you should have been doing
but you weren't you know it's like what
I'm gonna hate the guy because he's
[ __ ] good just drives me [ __ ] not
it's like just it takes me back to being
a Boston sports fan before we started
winning and it was just there was just
like how many [ __ ] times can these
[ __ ] get the call how many times can
just the ball just [ __ ] bounce into
this guy's hand like just getting the
brakes like Mercedes got really [ __ ]
lucky today oh
or what I think that just a better team
I don't know what the [ __ ] deal is
was Ferrari they make some of the
greatest cars in history that just I
don't know it was frustrating I was
really hoping you know the first five
they get five six races in and and
Ferrari had like a nice decent lead and
then to watch Mercedes play catch-up for
once it's just you know it's just not
it's not that time so we shall see we
shall see what happens anyways let me
see what we got here
Andrew was asking me if I wanted to
answer any more of these [ __ ] tax
questions which I you know I'll do it
I'll answer another one I don't know I
just have no [ __ ] idea how you're
gonna convince me that you should
basically punish honest Americans who
happen to be making over ten million
dollars a year
and the fact that you would co-sign on
that as a fellow American to punish
those [ __ ] people and make them pay
for all these people who don't pay any
amount any taxes all these corporations
that don't pay any taxes all these
corporations that [ __ ] drag us into
these never-ending [ __ ] Wars
never-ending [ __ ] Wars and make a
[ __ ] fortune off of death and
destruction and that's all separate
issue it's all a [ __ ] separate issue
and you know what you know what we can
[ __ ] tax these people because they
actually report their [ __ ] income so
goddamn it I'm not making ten million a
year so [ __ ] them well I'm not making
ten million a year either and I don't
say [ __ ] them I don't leave him the [ __ ]
alone
and go after the [ __ ] problem
alright don't paint a house that has a
broken foundation or that needs a new
foundation I should say alright oh by
the way I'm gonna be in New York City
Tuesday flying in Tuesday morning
getting off the plane going right over
to MSG for the garden of dreams and you
know what they're saying dreams okay it
ain't [ __ ] the main room
with a nixon the [ __ ] rangers play
because that's the garden of nightmares
I'm talking about the theater at Madison
Square Garden where Eddie Murphy
recorded raw legendary place the garden
of dreams and I'm on this [ __ ] show
unbelievable show that has let me let me
read the line up here because Brian
Regan was tweeting about it I had no
idea
listen listen to this [ __ ] garden of
dreams April 2nd come on bill type
faster here we go
though at the Hulu Theater all-star
lineup announced all right listen to
this we're waiting bill it is jesus
[ __ ] christ
Tiffany Haddish Michael che Brian Regan
Jerry Seinfeld Jon Stewart Jon Stewart
John Mulaney
I thought Eliza Schlesinger was on it I
don't know and yours truly oh and also
steve Schirripa is going to be hosting
it typical me I don't even know what the
[ __ ] this is for and you will all start
benefit that is raise nearly five
million dollars so far for what Gardner
Dreams Foundation is nonprofit with 30
partnering organizations throughout the
tri-state area including hospitals wish
organizations in queue okay all Gardner
dreams make-a-wish okay it's like a
make-a-wish thing okay cool so I'll be
doing that Oh Billy new jokes coming to
town what did I [ __ ] eat my [ __ ]
freckled dick the other night Jesus
Christ I took a nice fat one at the
[ __ ] belly room went up there was
some new jokes oh my god terrible
[ __ ] terrible I had this great
[ __ ] thing on people who are watching
that Michael Jackson [ __ ] documentary
it absolutely [ __ ] destroyed
destroyed and then the
every next night two nights later I go
to do it and I never take myself because
I just I you know because I know I'm not
gonna listen to it I wish I taped that
night because I went and tried to do the
same thing and all I got was groans so
that might just be one of those things
where you know one night it worked and
it just never worked again then I just
sit there you know like somebody who had
loved and then lost it I'm speaking of
having loved it having lost it let's
read a little bit of the advertising
here the [ __ ] that I do with it MMP
content all right here we go
live reads the reads that are live oh
wait tonight did I attach them no I did
oh look who it is you have a buy
something online only to find out later
you missed a discount I don't know did I
how the [ __ ] would I find that out when
I'm an old lady
are there coupons on the internet I had
no I didn't know about this [ __ ] anyways
don't overspend anymore go to honey is a
free browser add-on that finds you the
best deals online the app magically Auto
applies the best deal to your cart at
checkout honey finds discounts and
coupons across 37 thousand sites isn't
that amazing
Amazon Sephora Best Buy Nordstrom in war
honey is saved it's ten million ten
million members an average of twenty
eight dollars and 61 cents weight per
purchase well it depend on what you buy
that's a little vague members have
already saved more than 800 million
dollars Jesus Christ
not bad for some I guess that means per
purchase 10 million turns into 800
billion not bad for something that's
completely free and takes just two
clicks to install this thing is free
well you know they probably tracked
something I mean nothing's free in this
world is it is it honey hey
he has over 100,000 five-star reviews on
Google Chrome store Time magazine calls
honey basically free money look there's
really no reason not to use honey it's
free to use and easy to install on your
computer in just two clicks so shop with
confidence get honey for free at join
honey dot-com / / that's join honey
dot-com / / the smart shopping assistant
that saves you time and money when
you're shopping online oh look who's
next oh I only have two reeds I love it
policy genius hey can you [ __ ]
believe it's April already do you know
it says that people who don't live in
towns that have [ __ ] the winner or
part of the world you don't I mean I
remember Massachusetts January February
and the the horrific hope of March in
like a lamb I like a lie no no it just
sucked 31 [ __ ] days of it before I
had to [ __ ] pay you know rent and
everything
February always [ __ ] dragged even
though it was only twenty eight days it
was still the middle of [ __ ] oh wait
you got your February vacation though
that was kind of cool when I was in
school anyways can you believe it's
already April time has a habit of
getting away but if you have a mortgage
kids already or depending on your income
you're gonna have to spend some of that
precious time to get life insurance if
you need life insurance but you don't
want to spend a lot of time comparing it
you should give policy genius a try
policy genius is the easy way to buy
life insurance online it's just two
minutes you can compare in just two
minutes you can compare quotes from the
top insurers and find out the best price
once you apply the policy genius team
will handle all of the paperwork and the
red tape no Commission's no hidden fees
just more time saved for you so if you
need life insurance but you're not but
you're short on time head to policy
genius calm and comparequotes policy
genius is easy it saves you money and
not to belabor the point but it's fast
what policy
is easy it saves you money and not to
belabor the point it's it should just
say it's fast not but it's it's fast I
don't know policy genius spend less time
comparing life insurance and more time
doing literally anything else alright
let's get back to the podcast here all
right
MotoGP had their second race of the year
I know Mike Mike has wanted I didn't get
a chance to watch it yet I'm gonna try
to do that I'm gonna finish this podcast
and hang out with my little beautiful
kid here and and then I might check that
out tonight cuz I ain't doing [ __ ] I'm
not doing [ __ ] tonight hanging out with
the wife gonna go get a little quality
time in there I did a benefit Saturday
night at the Palace Theatre here in
downtown LA I got to play drums the
portion of the show that I was on was
it's an MS benefit Rock Against MS and
just a great event I've done it twice
Antibes sale puts the thing together
it's always this great make seven quite
amusing that I I grew up watching and I
get you know when I get to sit in with
all these [ __ ] great people and I
played highway to hell which I think I
played live at this time like a half a
dozen times but this is the first time I
played it where I I felt like I had the
least amount of fuck-ups you know it's
funny in the middle that's such an easy
song to [ __ ] up at least at my level
because you know in the middle where
he's going don't stop me bad on a bad
and a bad you know it's sort of it's
like a three against four thing so he's
supposed to kind of one and two and
three and four one two three four one
and two and three and four and one and
two and three four really simple but in
my head whenever I'm playing this song
cuz I played that song a million [ __ ]
times and never thought about it I could
just feel it but all of a sudden I'm
playing it I'm not playing along the
track and I got [ __ ] people I grew up
watching on MTV it's turning around
looking at me I get [ __ ] it [ __ ] me
up right so that one is basically I
always here it is
one and A two into three and I'm just
like oh no where am I I was playing
along to ac/dc and I just started
thinking about it and all of a sudden I
was [ __ ] it up playing along the
highway I played along that song if
thirty four thirty [ __ ] years never
thought about it
alright the day of the gig I'm playing
along to it and I'm thinking about this
part going I mean I got least I got to
know how to count this out figure out
what this is after all these years of
playing it and I started [ __ ] it up
so I'm backstage just going I'm going
one and two and three and four one and
two and three and four and one and two
and three four like I'm gonna do that so
of course when you know the time comes
so the song [ __ ] comes you know we
start playing the [ __ ] song we get to
that point Michael Devon from Whitesnake
is singing and immediately I started you
know but i depotted abun I had no idea
so I just [ __ ] went real hard with
the hi-hat so my my one would be there
one what well and then you know I ended
up getting out of it and I had a great
[ __ ] time I had the drum sounded
awesome and I got to watch all these
guys Stephen Perkins who was just on my
podcast I got to watch him play my
favorite Van Halen song of all time mean
streets and does it mean streak this is
home this is Main Street its Main Street
the movies mean streets I got to watch
him play that and just an incredible
[ __ ] drummer man you know some people
look like they're working when they're
playing that guy looks up they're like
he's just having the time of his [ __ ]
life and I got to go on like right after
him and he's just he's the best [ __ ]
dude ever so I'm hoping he's actually
gonna be playing out live here where I
can watch him do a full set that's what
the [ __ ] I would really like something
what am I talking about he promoted that
thing in the beginning of April am I
gonna be around for that I think I am
hopefully I am that thing in downtown LA
now I'm literally just talking to myself
I'm not even doing a [ __ ] podcast
anymore
let's get to some of the questions here
for the week I know the Red Sox have won
one and lost two I love when they said
the Red Sox have given up 18 runs and
they're past two games and I was like
Jesus Christ we're getting lit up and
then I see we only let up six the other
night it's like all right so we let up
twelve one night that [ __ ] happens
all right let's get to let's get to some
of the questions here for the week see
what I got here I'm hoping I'm not gonna
get trashed too much for my [ __ ] my
views here on taxes all right athletes
getting paid hey Bill Ricci on your
podcast you talked a little bit about
why College Ashley athletes should get
paid yeah but I also think that it
should be like a flat fee so you don't
have to bring in agents or anything like
that they do a straight across the
[ __ ] board socialism thing here so
you don't have high school hold outs and
all of that or maybe that is the wrong
thing I have no idea I was just saying
starters get this amount of money and if
you have a jersey that sells a lot you
get a percentage of it and then
everybody else who isn't a starter gets
a certain amount of [ __ ] money and
then that's it straight across the
[ __ ] board bing bang boom done all
right hey Bill okay and I wanted to
chime in on why it's harder than it
seems not just because of the greedy
corporate [ __ ] oh no it's it's [ __ ]
it'll be a [ __ ] nightmare that's why
I'm proposing a one sort of you know I
don't know it's just [ __ ] up that
somebody is like selling a zillion
jerseys with their name on the back just
coming from show business I just know if
I sold out a football [ __ ] stadium
that I would get paid for it I would
never do that show for free unless I
guess it was a benefit but I can't see a
football stadium worth of people this is
weird thing where it's like you're
coming in as a blue-chip draft pick out
of a recruit I should say out of high
school and then you're going to Michigan
or US
see or Alabama like these places they're
gonna sell out anyways because of the
history so it's almost like you're
joining a supergroup right but it's kind
of like the original members leave and
now you have to carry on the name so at
first they're doing you a favor but once
you establish yourself as a star then
you're the one that's continuing your
the other draw that people are going to
at that point they know you [ __ ] name
and that's there's got to be some sort
of money I would think you know anyways
I'll also try to use simple language
because I know you can't read out loud
worthless [ __ ] and neither can i well I
like the fact that you're
self-deprecating deprecating - alright
paying athletes is all about who gets
the larger and smaller pieces of the pie
do football players get more than
basketball players or soccer players do
physical sports or activities get more
than mentally exhausting sports or
activities and what counts as a sport or
an athlete should the Chess Club a
racquetball players also get their share
of money now you know what I mean I'm
talking [ __ ] you're you're already
famous
you're such a big-time [ __ ] college
player you're already famous that's what
I mean look sit listen alright
I would limit it to the sports at the
school that have actually built the
dorms you know what I mean
built a new [ __ ] swimming pool for
the [ __ ] swim team I mean give me a
[ __ ] break here
alright the amount of money that college
football and college basketball brings
in that's what the [ __ ] I'm talking
about all right and then lesser than
that is a handful of hockey programs at
least here in America and in baseball
but they don't bring in the money the TV
the March Madness the bowl games the
[ __ ] playoff system they now have
football I mean that's a whole other
[ __ ] level anyways basically the
universities are pieces of [ __ ] because
they take the federal student aid money
and then take a broadcasting and they
then take broadcasting companies money
and pay [ __ ] nobody
in return it's smart but it's also a
total dick move okay we're all on the
same page here my thoughts are that
schools who are getting money from any
source of an event like the NCAA
tournament college football playoff or
the Presidents Cup Chess Championships
well how much [ __ ] money is that
should be contributing to the players in
some way medical travel shoes chess
boards and so on miss Kay you sound like
a chess player to me man you bringing up
chess way too much and is for the slices
of pie the amount kick back to the
athletes should be proportional sorry
had to use one big word Jesus guys am i
this bad [ __ ] talking to me like I
have brain damage okay to the amount of
the universe to the amount iam the
universe and then I stumble over the
next five words all right point taken
you guys are right the university
receives from the event it's [ __ ] up
it's [ __ ] up how to solve the paying
athletes problem but something is better
than nothing anyways I'm a longtime
listener saw you in Portland Oregon last
summer keep being great and stay safe on
your upcoming travels sincerely nobody
no name left to go [ __ ] yourself yeah
they should probably do so I would think
that they it doesn't make any seamount
of money that they're you know
generating and then I love that argument
the gating of free education it's like
yeah you know it's like they're going
there to play football and try to make
it into the NFL and their body and their
brain is never gonna be the same they're
gonna do damage to their body that
they're gonna feel for the rest of their
[ __ ] life okay they don't have time
to [ __ ] go to class and do all of
that [ __ ] especially during the football
season can you imagine getting ready to
play for Alabama and making sure you're
turning your paper in and at the same
time they get a free education no they
think in an education I feel like the
music business is almost that's it's
that much of a [ __ ] over even the music
business Jesus Christ they back in the
day they let you keep you [ __ ] tour
money and your t-shirt you merch money
right
I don't know all right the number 70 hey
Bill simply put I think the interesting
thing about the 70 percent tax rate
argument is that most of the people
arguing for it don't even know why 70 I
would be one of those people the Green
Deal doesn't really just justify 70 or
make it any more important than say 65
the team behind aoc I don't know what
that is gave her that number her team is
essentially socialists they're trying to
make a capitalist argument in support of
a socialist idea and socialism there is
no end game and like fascism it's a
small group of people making decisions
for everyone that's the capitalism is
that way too
we really gotta stop like acting like
capitalism you know yeah anybody can
just pull themselves up by the
bootstraps like this things aren't like
lockdown you know if that was true we
would not have the gas combustion engine
for as long as we have if that was true
we would deal with global warming
head-on
yeah well all forms of government
socialism fascism capitalism whatever
the [ __ ] you want to call them they're
all inherently flawed because they're
run by human beings who are inherently
flawed yours truly
one of the great cases of all time
anyways unless we wipe out all the
Congress and replace the millionaires
with average joe's who care about the
earth and people and being fair they'll
just use that power to spend all our
money on selfless selfish causes it's
human nature it absolutely is and that's
it that's another part of my argument
it's like okay so these are the tax
dollars that are they're actually going
to use you know so public schools are
better at get health care fix the roads
help out the people in Flint Michigan
you know help out veterans this these
are the tax doral dollars they're
actually gonna get to them and they're
not they're not it is a broken system
I'm just hoping to find folks at
Blackwater you know they have the
weaponry to have a full-on [ __ ]
revolution hopefully their hearts are in
the right place
who knows we shall see friend is a flat
earther what I don't understand how this
this made a comeback I really feel like
this is just people trolling I just
can't imagine that this is this is an
actual thing I mean God knows I'm not a
[ __ ] smart guy okay what the [ __ ]
people are gonna sit here and act as
though this is actually a thing how did
this start friend is a flat earther
hey pili global tits at you know it's
the best one in a while I'm a 28 year
old living in New York one of my best
friends is a flat earther not only him
but his girlfriend is well well you know
they [ __ ] missionary style huh where do
they call it earth style
I know I've known them for over five
years so recently I sent him a cool
video of to space is that X or 10
Rockets vertically landing I would
expect his normal reaction like oh
that's so cool it's amazing what people
can do nowadays but instead of that he
started talking about how we've been
lied to the whole time that all the
space program Isis and all of that is a
global hoax oh man he went way down the
rabbit hole why I started down that road
and I headed back so I thought he was
joking and I asked him are you a flat
earner earther and he responded do
research bro
okay wait a second you know something I
want to take this guy's advice and I'm
gonna do a little research here flat
earth evidence I can't imagine with the
advertising I'm gonna get no science
sell me a hazmat suit and a [ __ ]
shelter frequent Flat Earth frequently
asked questions what Evans do you have
10 easiest way you can tell for yourself
the earth is not flat this is
what this is what proves the evident
like all these smarmy people taking all
this time on can you imagine like if you
know the world's [ __ ] round right
you've been in a plane you looked at it
you've seen it flat or maybe they just
[ __ ] nearsighted people they can't
see the roundness of the earth when they
get up at 37,000 feet flatter if the
Flat Earth model is an architect concept
the Flat Earth explained okay and the
weirdest part isn't just that he
believes the earth is flat I can't find
anybody that says seven ways to prove
the earth is round you know what because
I'm on page one why the earth is
actually a hundred percent flat okay
hang on a second is this the one and you
know I gotta hit pause because I want to
read these things hold on
okay I'm back all right I just found a
guy he goes you know luck for you guys
say I'm a [ __ ] I did a was on the math
team and I want a jury trial which are
very difficult to win and I used to
think that the world was round until I
met my Lord and Savior Jesus Christ
forty years ago it's like okay alright
alright I'm out tap it out god bless you
god bless you god bless all the flat
earthers so what do they think they
think the earth is round but the flat
but the moon is round how does the water
not run off the ends I mean I
flown around the world I've done it I
did a gig I flew from LA to Australia
then I did Australia to [ __ ] New
Zealand and then I went to Singapore
that I went to China that I went to
India then I went to New York I
connected in Dubai we kept flying that
[ __ ] another way granted I didn't have a
compass he could have done a big slow
[ __ ] and all the pilots in on it uh you
know I mean with the fly don't know what
the [ __ ] I'm going you know that'd be
really easy to fake you faked you out in
a plane you know just for a few times
when I try to do a little bit of
instrument training in the helicopter
and they have you close your eyes and
they just start doing [ __ ] and you can
just you have no [ __ ] idea what's
going on and I go you know if you sit in
the back of a plane you just looking out
the side of it you don't know what's
going on hey man you know what maybe it
is flat man I don't know I just
Jesus Christ this guy found Jesus and
the result of it was he thinks the
[ __ ] world is flat ok anyways I've
known them for over five years let's
just get back to this [ __ ] thing ok
so he said do your research bro the same
day I called him and his girlfriend over
to over to my house alright well I just
looked at a guy who said he was a
mathlete and he believes the world is
flat you believe it's around and you
just wrote a fragment so right now the
flat earthers are winning the same day I
called him and his girlfriend over to my
house period anyways I'm gonna tell you
old freckles I had much fun arguing with
them but his response was I knew you
were gonna make fun of us not take us
seriously I didn't I didn't mean to tell
you it just slipped out of my mouth next
time I'll be cautious now this is very
unusual behavior for him he never had
been so sensitive and cautious on any
level
his biggest argument is that it's
written in the Koran the Bible and the
Torah that the earth is flat God laid
the earth beneath our feet like a carpet
for us to walk on well he could still do
that and could be round
ceil gravity thing right
I respect religion but like it but like
a comedy I cannot take it literally it's
all written in poetic manner right it's
been almost a week and I'm arguing with
him only about this topic my question is
is flat earther the new gay should I
close this topic and accept his new
enlightened perspectives or should I be
worried about continuing to throw
scientific facts at them is that what
you do with gay people look you both
have vaginas ok you can't penetrate one
another how much more scientific fact do
you need that the two of you lesbians
should have a threesome with me anyways
I don't want to escalate this thing to
the breaking point
but it feels like they're in some cult
and since they are my friends I care I
listen regularly to you to your podcast
always from Casca Stan oh alright
alright so I'll forgive the fragments
here and this is my first time writing
sorry for my English your English was
great thanks and go [ __ ] yourself
I don't know how things work in Casca
Stan but over here in the good ole
United States of America your friendship
with them is hit a serious snag in the
road so I mean you can continue to be
friends with somebody that thinks the
world is flat just don't bring it up
it's like religion you know there's a
bunch I mean I'm not into it but I I
don't know how people I mean I hung out
with people Scientologists seem to be
like the only people around my age that
still [ __ ] practice their religion I
don't they don't [ __ ] bug me I just
don't bring up religion I'm not gonna
[ __ ] bombard them with my stupid
opinions my unresearched opinions who
gives a [ __ ] you know what the funny
thing is is the only reason why you and
I know that the earth is [ __ ] around
is because of other human beings that
had the balls to [ __ ] get in a
goddamn
and start sailing off into it so I can't
only make fun of these people so much
okay you're talking about somebody who
took his daughter a two year old to a
[ __ ] Tim Burton movie so I mean how
much Oh far away am i from someone who
thinks the [ __ ] world is flat but
having said that I feel like you're
eventually gonna slowly back away from
these two people if they continue down
that road yeah I also get nervous that
you know people were gonna make fun of
them to the point that they become angry
people and then all of a sudden yeah
you're the person that they take their
anger out on these are just concerns
that I have all right boyfriend wants to
become a comedian by the way thanks for
listening to the podcast way over there
don't you guys have a race over there
one of the f1 races over there and one
of those K countries boyfriend wants to
become a comedian a Billy bald eagle my
boyfriend of almost two years told me
when we started dating that he's been
torn between being a comedian or being a
doctor yes I knew a guy that actually
quit being a comedian to go back to med
school
he's ridiculous ridiculously smart and I
know he can do anything he puts his mind
to
so are you're here but I personally feel
like he'd make a bigger difference in
the world being a doctor and if anything
could be easier to transition from being
a doctor to a comedian than the other
way around well first of all it's not
your life and it's not your dream and I
can tell you that this is a young man
and woman's business so all those years
of studying to be a doctor and then
become a comedian that's it said there
could be a difficult thing I love him
and I've told him that I'll support him
no matter what he chooses but I person
but I personally think doctor is the way
to go is it the underlining thing that
you don't think he's funny cuz then I
get this
anyways yes I realized that it sounds
like a [ __ ] gold digger but that's
not why I want him to go for it I
couldn't give a [ __ ] about what he
brings home that's [ __ ]
that's complete [ __ ] why why
wouldn't you give a [ __ ] that's the
first thing women ask what do you do
that's the guy's job the guy's job is to
provide the woman's job is to stay home
in the kitchen making babies but that's
seriously I mean that that is the thing
as much as women want to put on pants
and go out and down the street wearing a
[ __ ] hardhat you know you're always
going to be working with guys because I
mean what we can't make a baby you know
week we can you know we can start the
[ __ ] process but we're in the pit
crew you're driving around the [ __ ]
track you're the ones gonna have the
[ __ ] kid so you know all right my
[ __ ] record of [ __ ] crap down for
some reason it's still in the left
[ __ ] Channel why is it doing this
[ __ ] why does it do this you know what
about this does this make it better does
this is this both sides no it is it no
it isn't you know what I'm gonna have to
buy a new recorder cuz I don't I don't
make I'll make this [ __ ] thing work I
was saying yeah there's nothing wrong
ladies with what's asking what a guy
does for a living that's what you should
be asking cuz you you want to you want
to get what a smart guy okay where it
becomes gold-digging is if you just tell
a guy that you love him when you don't
because of what he's making
and then you marry him and then
eventually you can't live the lie
anymore and you take him for everything
he's got in his [ __ ] house okay but
if you're just trying to because you
don't want to marry a [ __ ] dope man
it's good for the human race you're
smart enough huh
if you're smart enough to not marry a
dope then you're gonna make smart people
who hopefully do good things so by all
means ladies keep asking what do you do
for a living
you know there's questions that need to
be asked you know that's basically the
female the females should ask that the
same way guys should be like are those
things real okay we're both doing our
research anyways
I think that that guy like I said you
know is he I think he wants to be a
comedian and his parents don't support
him so that's always great for the
comedy and he sounds like a really smart
guy if he's smart enough to be torn
between the two of them I've made that
both great jobs you know and they both
really help people um all right what can
i end with let me end with this on this
one [ __ ] speaker why is it doing this
I have everything set the way I normally
said that's got to be something on the
mixer I'm never gonna figure this out
stereo existing is this what I need to
do did that fix any something just
happened hello hello I like the way that
sounds this does this work and then this
and then this I'm just a this is how I
play video games I just start pushing
the buttons nothing happens it's how we
do staying up too I just push buttons
congratulations to Ronny Chang comic I
saw a long time ago on a [ __ ] plane I
was like this guy's funny as hell and
then he opened for me in Australia and
then he got on The Daily Show and now he
just booked an acting role in this
sitcom acid I guess so now an
african-american woman also both so
congratulations both of them but
unfortunately the stars are white so now
people are saying I'm not gonna watch
the you know 15 people on the internet
are saying they're not gonna [ __ ]
watch it it's just you know I don't know
I'm too white to understand all of that
it's just like alright so you're not
gonna watch a show because of somebody's
skin it's just a joke we're sick of this
alright okay so if I do that I'm racist
but if you do it because if you add
oppression to it and the fact that white
people created this situation you're
you're I'm not gonna use I hate that
expression woke it's just been overused
so I don't know I don't know what the
[ __ ] math is on it I just hope people
watch it cuz I love Ronny Chang all
right there can everybody just [ __ ]
relax the world is going to a head to
hell in a [ __ ] handbasket the first
mammal is extinct from [ __ ] global
warming sorry climate change
am I in trouble at transgendered people
did I use the wrong [ __ ] terminology
there and we're running around freaking
out about [ __ ] sitcoms and [ __ ]
gender-neutral bathrooms are way way way
more up on the list of priority than
there's not gonna be any [ __ ] for us to
[ __ ] argue about maybe that is the
end game I have no idea I like what
people go I don't think that there's a
god why could there be a god if he would
just if you just look at the [ __ ]
world and it's just like well look you
know they made absolute masterpiece
masterpieces of automobiles and people
bought them and then they just [ __ ]
sat in a barn does that mean the people
that made them all of a sudden it's not
a [ __ ] masterpiece well I guess
that's not a good thing because the car
would act like how human beings do I
don't know maybe God is like you know
like a crazy artist you know I mean and
yes this is like our world is just
something he just you know those people
that don't they don't really paint they
just throw [ __ ] paint at a canvas
when they get naked and they roll around
on it they have to put turpentine in
their pubes afterwards and somehow after
they die it's like worth like [ __ ] 10
million bucks maybe that's what he did I
have no idea but anyway I'm gonna watch
it because Ronny Chang's in it and as a
white person I love I love a white lead
I'm not racist I'm just a proud white
podcaster I'm [ __ ] around I don't I
don't watch it Cubs I watched I watched
sports and I'm gonna go watch the MotoGP
but I guess that's it right I'm gonna do
the Garden of Dreams on April 2nd I'll
check in on you on Thursday
and hopefully I can have somebody fix
this [ __ ] recorder I don't know what
the problem is you know what the problem
is it's me so I apologize all right I'll
see